[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад, я дуже радий
бачити вас сьогодні,
і дозвольте мені представити нашого сьогоднішнього гостя, тому
передайте привіт Mr.  Пол, привіт
, Пол розкажи трохи про себе. Я
вчитель англійської мови і вчитель спорту
в Україні вже десять років, і моє
улюблене хобі - це тільки добре готувати здорову їжу,
можливо, ти зрозумів, що
сьогодні ми поговоримо про
фізичні вправи та харчування Павло, до речі,
який твій улюблений вид спорту,
мабуть, мій улюблений вид спорту - регбі, але
для мене тепер, коли я стаю старшим, я просто
кажу, щоб залишатися дуже здоровим і здоровим,
тому яка твоя улюблена українська страва я
мав би бути борщем  але не звичайний
бос Мені подобається одинокий бос, так що добре, хлопці,
ми готові продовжити наш урок,
тому ось слова, які вам знадобляться
для цього уроку, подивіться на цей
банк словників, щоб
ви могли побачити, що у нас є вуглеводи
переклад, щоб допомогти вам потім білкові
жири служать витривалості Пол, чи можете ви
навести приклад витривалість витривалість - це коли
вам потрібно робити багато вправ, і ви продовжуєте
працювати, і ви можете робити це протягом тривалого часу,
ви не дуже втомлюєтеся сьогодні ми використовували
w  ords витривалість більше правильно так так,
ймовірно, витривалість краще використовувати
добре, потім приходить сила, і приклад,
будь ласка, це означає, що у вас багато
сили у всьому вашому тілі, але особливо
ваші
руки добре, гм гнучкість щось на зразок
йоги та розтяжки робить вас дуже
гнучким, якщо  ви можете торкатися пальцями ніг,
не згинаючи ніг, ви дуже
гнучкі, добре, але якщо я займаюся підняттям тяжкості
, чи потрібно бути гнучким,
не обов'язково занадто гнучким, але
завжди добре потім потягнутися, щоб
запобігти травмам,
інакше кажучи ефективно  ефективний, що
це означає, що це означає працювати майже до максимальної
потужності, але не втомлюючись, щоб
ви могли виконувати справи, не використовуючи
весь свій ресурс енергії, добре, тоді
схуднення дуже популярне слово для заняття
спортом, і останнє - це набирати м'язи
добре  хлопці ще раз, будь ласка,
слідкуйте за Mr.  Пол, читаючи ці слова
, містить вуглеводи, їжу, яка дає вам
енергію, білки, їжу, яка нарощує
м’язовий жир, а також дає вам енергію та
підтримує вас в теплі порції розміром з їжею,
яку ви їсте, витривалість або витривалість
сила гнучкість ефективність або
ефективна втрата ваги киснем і збільшення м’язової
маси  добре, сьогодні ми
поговоримо спочатку про вправи, тому Пол,
що ти конкретно робиш
у спортзалі, які твої регулярні
тренування, не просто ходи в спортзал, якщо я треную
приблизно 10 чи 12 разів на
тиждень  половина його буде кардіо
вранці, щоб знизити вагу, щоб скинути
трохи жиру, а ввечері я б пішов
у спортзал, і це було б для набору м’язів,
але що б
ви порекомендували нашим дітям, що б ви
порекомендували  підлітки
Я б не рекомендував робити те, що я роблю, але,
можливо, я б порекомендував три різні
види вправ добре, хлопці, це заняття з
читання, яке ми хочемо, щоб ви прочитали
разом із Mr.  опитування, і ми зупинимося, і
ми поставимо вам запитання про те, що ви
прочитали, добре, тож, будь ласка, слідкуйте за Mr.
опитування читання тексту добре, ось
, здорове тіло – це міцне, гнучке тіло,
яке може продовжувати працювати протягом
тривалого періоду, тому важливо
виконувати наступні три різні види
вправ, перша одна аеробна вправа,
яка змушує нас використовувати цей вид вправ  більше
кисню і чудово підходить для нашого серця або
вашого серця, коли ви часто виконуєте аеробні вправи,
часті аеробні вправи,
ви розвиваєте витривалість, тому можете продовжувати
займатися тривалий час, ваше тіло
не втомлюється відразу, тому що ваше
серце стає дуже ефективним у посиленні
кисню вашим  працюють м'язи деякі
приклади аеробних вправ
плавання баскетбол їзда на велосипеді та танці
добре немає інших питань, тому Ольга,
що саме дає аеробна вправа
для вас, ви бачите, він хоче, щоб я виношував
студента, тепер добре аеробні вправи це
допомагає мені принести кров до серця
щоб бути ефективнішим і мати кращу
таманну, це правильно, це чудово,
Ольга, ти уважно слухай, дякую добре,
друге запитання Ольга  будь ласка, наведіть мені кілька
прикладів видів спорту або видів діяльності, які
є аеробними вправами. Я точно
пам'ятаю плавання та танці, добре, непогано,
два з чотирьох, добре, давайте подивимося правильні
відповіді, ось вони, тож, що саме
це робить для вас, це робить ваше серце
ефективним для надсилання  кисень до ваших
м'язів і нарощує витривалість ви можете виконувати
вправи протягом тривалого часу,
і приклади, які я сказав, тільки танці та
плавання, але я пропустив баскетбол і
їзду на велосипеді, давайте йти далі
так, добре вправа, яка розвиває вашу
силу, коли ви виконуєте вправи, ви хочете,
щоб ваше серце  сильні, але ви також
хочете зробити свої м'язи сильними, це
допомагає вам бути активним і сповненим
енергії сильні м'язи також захищають ваше
тіло біг на велосипеді і ковзанах - все це
добре для сильних ніг, а деякі гімнастичні
вправи чудово підходять для сильних рук і
сильного живота, тут добре  ми переходимо до
питань добре Ольга більше питань для вас
добре, тренуйте, щоб розвинути свою силу
Ольга, що саме це робить для вас,
вони роблять мою музику  сильніші не
тільки мої ноги, але й усі м'язи, і я
можу стати плоским живіт, і чи можете ви розповісти
мені кілька прикладів спорту або діяльності,
які дають вам міцні м'язи. О, Пол,
вибач, що я не був таким уважним,
добре, цього разу прощаю тобі  Вибачте
добре, хлопці, давайте подивимося на відповіді, добре, тож,
що саме це робить для вас, це дає
вам сильні м’язи, які роблять вас активними
та сповненими енергії та допомагають
захистити ваше тіло, наприклад, біг на
велосипеді та ковзанах для ніг та
гімнастика для  Руки та живіт в порядку,
тому наступна вправа для покращення
гнучкості може допомогти зробити
вас гнучкими, що означає, що ваші м’язи
сильні, але вони також можуть легко рухатися, і
в багатьох різних положеннях вам потрібна
хороша гнучкість, щоб займатися деякими видами спорту, як-от
танці або плавання  але також грати у
футбол чи баскетбол, гімнастику йогу
та бойові мистецтва можуть допомогти вам
знову стати більш гнучкими.
Ці вправи
дають мені змогу вільно рухатися та уникати
травм я прав
так, ти частково права, Ольга, добре, чи
не могли б ви розповісти мені кілька прикладів спорту
чи занять, які дають вам гнучкість,
я точно знаю  що це йога-йога,
дуже відома своєю гнучкістю, добре, давайте
подивимося, що відповідь: хлопці, то що саме
вона робить для вас, вона дає вам
гнучкість, ви можете легко рухатися в багатьох
положеннях і таким чином пористі нашу гімнастичну
йогу та бойові мистецтва добре, тому ми
готові до  продовжити Павло, ти задав мені
декілька запитань,
тепер у мене є запитання, тож чи
можна показувати хороші результати
тільки тренуючись, це дуже гарне запитання,
Ольга, і, чесно кажучи,
самостійної роботи насправді недостатньо, навіть якщо
я витрачаю всі свої  протягом днів у тренажерному залі вам також
потрібно контролювати своє харчування,
тож чи правда, що 60% вашого успіху
залежить від вашого харчування, так, це
дуже вірно, це, мабуть, важливіше,
ніж тренування насправді  добре, давайте подивимося, тому
Павла ми часто бачимо в наших буксирах або
в Інтернеті
цю піраміду, чи можете ви прокоментувати
її так, це дуже відома піраміда, піраміда харчового
трикутника, і вона має чотири рівні,
і ці рівні містять більшість
макроелементів, найважливіші продукти
ви повинні їсти нормально, тож те, що на рівні 1
на рівні 1, в основному є вуглеводами, це
слово, яке ми бачили на початку вуглеводи,
такі як макарони з хлібними злаками,
це вуглеводи, які дають вам енергію,
вам слід намагатися їсти коричневі
версії та не забагато білого хліба, щоб
ви  означає, що торти не в порядку
торти не в нижній частині
піраміди, тому що в нижній частині
піраміди є основа і
найважливіші продукти торти не так важливі
Ольга добре так і рівень 2 я бачу, що є
фрукти та овочі
так, дуже відомі  фраза ви повинні їсти 5
порцій фруктів і овочів на день,
а рівень 2 стосується фруктів і
овочів, вони дають вам багато
вітамінів і мінералів, вони дуже
важливі, добре  Я знаю таке англійське
прислів'я яблуко в день
відволікає лікаря так, це дуже добре, але воно
говорить яблуко в день, одне яблуко в день, ви
можете з'їсти два-три, добре,
і так, три-п'ять порцій добре, так що
третій рівень добре  рівень третій, це
більше ваш білки речі, які допомагають вам
набрати м'язову масу або відновити ваші клітини, і
це такі речі, як м'ясо, риба, молочні
продукти, як-от молочний йогурт і сир, але,
звичайно, якщо у вас є молочні продукти,
ви повинні намагатися їсти знежирені продукти,
привіт  жир, але чи можна фруктовий
йогурт так, я впевнений, що іноді це
нормально, але як щодо цукру в цих
фруктових йогуртах так, це прихований
недолік цукру в цих йогуртах, які
я бачу, і рівень чотирьох жирів, олії та
солодощі, лише це, чого немає  справедливо так
, можливо, це несправедливо щодо солодощів, але
жири та олії є, навіть якщо в невеликій
кількості дуже важливі, вам
потрібен невеликий відсоток жирів,
корисні жири та олії у вашому раціоні,
такі як авокадо, оливкова олія, горіхи,
ці  дуже важливі жири добре Пол
зустрічай мого друга, це арена, вона
справжній чемпіон і вона чемпіонка
України, і вона дуже наполегливо тренується,
вона тренується кожен день плавання
важка атлетика і біг я думаю, що так,
якщо вона має якийсь інший
план харчування  оскільки всі ми допомагаємо О,
безперечно, Ольга, вона спалює багато
калорій щодня,
плавці спалюють багато калорій щодня
добре, Пол, що б ти порадив
Адіні
добре, є п'ять основних речей, які я б
порекомендував на арені, оскільки вона тренується
двічі на день  іноді, як сказала Ольга,
вона витрачає багато-багато енергії,
їй потрібно збільшити свої нормальні щоденні
калорії приблизно на п’ять-сімсот
більше, ніж звичайний підліток,
по-друге, вона тренується настільки наполегливо, що їй
потрібні сильні м’язи, а протеїн розвиває
міцні м’язи, тому їй слід
їсти мінімум 2 грами білка на
кілограм ваги, тому якщо вона важить
50 кілограмів, вона повинна їсти 100
грамів білка в день № 3-й
Найважливішим для арени є вуглеводи,
тому що вона плаває, ймовірно,
близько 2 годин щоранку, це
вимагає багато енергії, тому їй потрібно їсти
близько грамів або навіть
вуглеводів на кілограм
ваги, тому якщо вона важить 50 кілограмів, це означає, що
вона повинна  їсти від 150 до 200
грамів вуглеводів щодня. Вода номер 4, яка, як
ми всі знаємо, дуже важлива,
арена тренується дуже наполегливо, їй потрібно
пити багато води,
вона повинна пити 1 літр води
на 25 кілограмів ваги, тому якщо
ви  re 50 кілограмів, це 2 літри води,
якщо ти 100 кілограмів, як я, це 4
літри води щодня добре,
і номер 5 дуже важливих дітей, нам
потрібно спати мінімум 8-9 годин щодня,
якщо ти хочеш бути хорошим плавцем  або
навіть ти хочеш бути розумним у школі, тобі
потрібно спати 8 або 9 годин щоночі
добре, чудова порада для арени, і о, я
голодний Пол, о боже, я сподівався, що
ти запитаєш,
мені справді дуже потрібен перекус, на
щастя, я можу дати  ви з
перекусом, але це буде граматична закуска,
добре, хлопці, щоб бути здоровими і ногами,
вам потрібно добре харчуватися, і вам потрібно
тренуватися, щоб бути у формі англійської, ви повинні
знати
граматику та граматичні закуски, тож ви пам’ятаєте свої
домашні завдання ми запропонували вам
змінити речення на прості в минулому
чи пам'ятаєте ви ці речення я
бачив цей фільм до того, як ми прочитали три
англійські книги на уроці, моя мати
була в Лондоні двічі цього року
Джон позичив у мене чотири компакт-диски
діти  Ви снідали, і
ви випили всю каву, будьте тихо,
фільм почався, тому всі ці
питання в сучасному ідеальному, вам
довелося змінити їх на просто минуле, що
означало зміну не тільки слів, які ви
бачите червоним, але, можливо, ви щось додали
більше до цих речень давайте
подивимося на перше, яке я бачив
цей фільм раніше, щоб змінити його на
минуле просте мені потрібно зробити так, я бачив
цей фільм вчора, тому я змінив
форму дієслова і мені потрібно  щоб мати новий часовий
вираз вчора другий ми
прочитали три англійські книги в класі,
і я змінюю це так, ми
читали англійські книги минулого року знову, мені
довелося змінити форму дієслова та новий
вираз часу, тому наступна моя
мама  був у Лондоні двічі цього
року добре, і я відповіла: моя мама була
в Лондоні двічі в 2018 році, мені довелося
змінити форму та вираз
часу наступний Джон позичив у мене чотири компакт-диски
, щоб змінити цей я зробив це так
Тиждень тому Джон позичив у мене чотири компакт-диски,
тому тиждень тому я змінив форму дієслова та
новий вираз часу, щоб
наступні три
речення були швидшими, щоб діти з'їли
сніданок, ви випили всю каву
і мовчіть,
фільм почався  добре, я змінив
ці речення так, діти
поснідали п’ять хвилин тому, ви випили
всю холодну каву минулого разу і
мовчіть, фільм почався годину тому,
хлопці, я хочу, щоб ви зробили лайфхак, якщо
ви побачите, що ви спробували востаннє  nd дата
в минулому, як 2018, це безперечно
минуло, просто добре, хлопці, і якщо ви
ніколи не
робили це речення так, як і я  зробив,
і у вас не було проблем із цим добре,
Пол, я знаю, що у вас є виклик
так, у нас є завдання для вас сьогодні
добре,
як ви можете прочитати, завдання полягає в тому, щоб зробити
якомога більше віджимань за одну
хвилину, щоб усі дивилися  або
діти, які спостерігають за нами сьогодні, завдання
- це одна хвилина, якомога більше жимів
, але є правила для цього: ви повинні
тримати спину рівно, і ви повинні
мати ваші руки так само широкі, як ваші
плечі, тому прямі руки так само широкі,
як ваші плечі  і кожен раз грудьми до підлоги,
будь ласка, одну хвилину, якомога більше
жимів. ммм, це
складно, погано, можливо, якісь
зміни для дівчат, можливо, ми зможемо зробити
це на колінах
так, дуже гарна ідея, Ольга, тому для всіх
дівчата, ви можете поставити коліна на
підлогу, ті самі руки широкими грудьми до підлоги,
але тримайте коліна на підлозі, а не
прямі ноги,
і тому вони виконують це завдання протягом однієї
хвилини, і можуть відео себе так,
ми хочемо відео, будь ласка, добре, хлопці, тому якщо
ви  ви готові знімати відео та
надсилати нам свої відео, тому не соромтеся та
надсилайте їх мені в Instagram до Paul
L Low або зателефонуйте їй в Instagram, тож якщо
ви готові прийняти цей виклик,
ми чекаємо ваших відео зараз, Пол
я покажу вам, як ви повинні робити ці
жими, добре, перше, що
я скажу вам, це ви повинні тримати спину
прямо, руки повинні бути
широкими по плечах і ви повинні спробувати
підняти груди на підлогу, звичайно, якщо
ви  ти дівчина, тобі дозволено
згинати коліна й ставити коліна на
підлогу, я зараз продемонструю, тому Пол
готовий продемонструвати вам, як ви
повинні робити ці жими, добре, щоб моя
спина була прямою,
мої руки були поза моїми плечами.
груди збирається  підлога
гаразд, тож я показав вам, що робити,
усі знають, як це зробити правильно,
натискайте добре, хлопці, то тягніть, що було вашим
найкращим О, кілька років тому
я робив 74 за одну хвилину
74 за одну хвилину, коли  дивовижний номер,
хлопці, чи можете ви перемогти Пола так, давайте подивимося, хто
зможе перемогти мене добре, це кінець
уроку, ми сподіваємося побачити вас наступного разу, до побачення
[Музика]
ви